la visita de estado del presidente
Manuel mccoa china concluyó el 7 de
abril Pero sigue generando críticas
tanto en Francia como en uno de sus
aliados más importantes Al otro lado del
Atlántico Estados Unidos durante su
tercer día de visita macoon dio una
entrevista al medio francés le secó y al
estadounidense político en la que dio su
opinión sobre varios temas de política
internacional al abordar la atención
entre China y Taiwán el presidente
francés se desmarcó del discurso
estadounidense la pregunta que se nos
hace a los europeos es la siguiente
tenemos interés en acelerar el tema de
Taiwán no lo peor sería pensar que los
europeos deberíamos hacer lo mismo en
este tema y adaptarnos al ritmo y a una
sobre reacción china porque debemos ir
al ritmo elegido por otros los europeos
tenemos que despertar nuestra prioridad
no es adaptarnos a la agenda de otros en
todas las regiones del mundo algunos
senadores republicanos como del estado
de Indiana y Mike Gallagher Wisconsin
calificaron las palabras del presidente
francés como una traición ante el tono
de los senadores la Casa Blanca tuvo que
pronunciarse en las últimas horas para
calmar las aguas
dejaré que el presidente lo que quiera
estamos muy cómodos y confiados en la
fuerte Alianza y la fuerte amistad que
existe entre nuestros dos países y el
hecho de que hemos estado trabajando
juntos con Francia en el continente y en
otras partes del mundo
dentro de Francia también hay críticas
al encuentro del presidente macón con su
homólogo chino Pink analistas
consultados por radio Francia
internacional afirman que el encuentro
estaba condenado al fracaso porque China
tiene una postura inflexible sobre la
soberanía de Taiwán sin embargo desde el
Eliseo sostienen que el encuentro sirvió
para asentar las bases de una
desescalada de la atención entre China y